[Musica]
buona sera io sono emilia zamuner e
stasera vi presento la mia passione la
mia passione è il canto e volevo
cominciare con un video nel quale a soli
tre anni
cantavo le opere liriche vuole sentire
la voce ho cominciato così la mia
famiglia è una famiglia di musicisti da
loro ho imparato tanto
ho iniziato a leggere la musica prima
delle delle parole delle lettere
attraverso diciamo la loro passione è
nata anche la mia che è andata poi
trasformandosi nel tempo cantavo cantavo
le opere liriche ascoltavo tanta musica
classica e accompagnato al pianoforte
delle piccole e canzoncine e dei piccoli
brani che mia nonna mi aveva insegnato
anche lei pianista ha continuato fino
all'età di 89 anni fino a che lei mia
nonna morì pensai che la mia passione in
realtà era legata alla sua vita al a
tutto quello che avevo fatto insieme a
lei e quindi per un po di tempo non feci
nulla non canta e più canta e molto poco
fino a che un giorno mia madre mi disse
emilia sai che la nonna alle ultime sue
parole furono emilia deve cantare nella
sua vita e quindi ricomincia
inizialmente studia canto lirico al
conservatorio di salerno e per il primo
anno che ero lì avevo il corso
propedeutico perché poi non si può
iniziare a cantare lirica troppo giovani
mi resi conto che però ero molto stretta
in questa in questa in questo tipo di
musica mi piaceva ascoltarla ma non
riuscivo ad esprimere totalmente quella
che ero quindi iniziai a scoprire a
scoprire il mondo del canto in tutte le
sue sfaccettature
partendo dalla musica pop e poi però
arrivando al jazz
il jazz è stato qualcosa che
in me nato prima incontrandolo me ne
sono innamorata dopo che l'ho conosciuto
non sapevo assolutamente niente non
conoscevo nessun cantante mi volevo
iscrivere al conservatorio e studiare
studiare il canto
l'unico canto che c'era era canto jazz
entrai e c'erano ricordo ancora la
commissione con marco sannini carlo
lomanto e giulio martino che mi
guardarono e dissero ma che cosa cipe
cantare vuoi provare a improvvisare non
sapevo assolutamente cosa fosse lo
scatto cosa fosse tutta
l'improvvisazione che poi ci ha portato
insomma personaggi storici come la
fitzgerald e lui armstrong che hanno
inventato questo genere ho iniziato a
scoprirli e me ne sono innamorata ho
preso tantissime batoste ricordo ancora
la quantità di esami che marco sannini
mi fece rifare perché secondo lui ancora
non avevo studiato abbastanza e quindi
me cresceva l'amore è il voler fare bene
questa cosa crederci veramente perché la
passione non è soltanto qualcosa che
nasce e come l'amore
bisogna sempre coltivarlo fare in modo
che sia qualcosa per cui bisogna fare
dei sacrifici e 24 anni ne ho fatti
tanti ho perso tante amicizie tanti
compagni di viaggio proprio perché
scelsi la musica come mia passione è
arrivata poi al terzo anno di
conservatorio
i miei compagni mi dissero ma perchè non
provi ad iscriverti al premio massimo
urbani è stato per me poi il momento
diciamo di grande cambiamento della mia
vita questo perché conobbi un sacco di
musicisti e il premio massimo urbani è
stato è uno dei premi più importanti che
si che si fanno insomma in italia il
primo anno che provai
non passa neanche le selezioni diciamo
finali il secondo anno invece ero a
lezione in classe il conservatorio e
ricevetti la mail che ero passata ce
l'avevo fatta e non credevo però dissi a
mia madre c'erano erano tre giorni di
gara insomma tra i vari musicisti e il
terzo giorno dovevamo fare
bisognava fare insomma il concerto c'era
il concerto del vincitore
ricordo ancora che dissi a mia madre
mamma prenoto comunque la stanza
dell'albergo perché voglio ascoltare il
concerto del vincitore 20 anni di premio
massimo urbani vent'anni di musicisti
che avevano vinto se non un altro
cantante walter ricci grandissimo
cantante oltretutto della zona casertana
e walter diciamo fu l'unico cantante che
vinse quindi ho assolutamente insicura
arrivai con la mia unica grande passione
quella del canto e dissi vabbeh ci provo
e questo infatti è proprio il momento in
cui ho avuto il piacere di suonare poi
con quelli che erano anche i giudici
della somma del premio è lì dietro
dietro di mese un contrabbassista
fantastico dal nome massimo moriconi il
quale è stato il contrabbassista storico
di mina registrato con lei ben trenta
dischi e quando mi presentai portai la
parte insomma sul a tutti i musicisti
dissi proprio al massimo allora facciamo
questo arrangiamento poi il pezzo va
normale e lui mi disse che cos'è per te
la normalità ognuno di noi vede la
normalità a modo suo io magari mi
sveglio alle 10 del mattino e posso
pensare che per me è normale svegliarmi
a quest'ora chi va a lavorare più presto
ovviamente a un'altra un altro modo di
vivere la vita e quindi mi trovai in un
momento di calma totale per di sì va
bene posso anche solo cantare non aver
paura di nulla dietro a tre personaggi
così non potevo che
essere a mio agio e il premio massimo
urbani poi mi ha portato eccola la
vittoria del premio massimo urbani mi ha
portato poi a lavorare tanto lavorare
tanto con tantissimi progetti ea
conoscere moltissimi musicisti e a
vedere che in tutti loro c'era una
grandissima passione
quindi ognuno di loro cerca sempre
soprattutto attraverso il jazz
c'è tanto di questo perché abbiamo la
possibilità di improvvisare quindi di
raccontarci ogni giorno in maniera
diversa a seconda del pubblico che ci
troviamo di fronte a seconda delle
situazioni in cui ci troviamo anche di
location di posti di formazioni è reso
quindi tutto sempre più interessante e
quindi ogni mio sogno che diventava
realtà diventava un nuovo punto di
partenza un nuovo una nuova passione che
si accendeva in me e quindi prima di
andare avanti vorrei farvi sentire
diciamo un piccolo pezzetto di quello
che poi un brano che ormai mi mi
rappresenta un brano di oggi carmichael
intitolato the nearness of view
[Musica]
e ovvio
il cav
[Musica]
già stamane
se sì un brano molto semplice non ho
voluto improvvisare tantissimo
improvvisa e la serata prima continua e
quindi su questa strada di un breve di
un breve insomma il pezzo molto semplice
per poter esprimere poi quella che era
la mia la mia anima veramente la mia
passione e dopo questo insomma sono nate
delle collaborazioni prima fra tutte
quella appunto con massimo moriconi con
il quale abbiamo fatto un duo basso e
voce
una follia totale anche perché massimo è
un po matto da una persona che ha
lavorato tanto con la musica è veramente
con tanti grandi artisti e vi racconto
questa cosa mi disse sai che a me non
piace tanto su una quei cantanti
però mi sono divertito con tre commina
con maria pia de vito e conte per me
avevo finito già di fare qualsiasi altra
cosa era stato forse uno dei momenti più
belli della mia vita ho detto allora
forse quello che sto facendo lo sto
facendo realmente bene tanti sacrifici e
tanti a volte tra virgolette litigi con
la mia famiglia perché da musicisti
classici avevano seguito completamente
diciamo degli orari delle idee
completamente diverse quindi la figlia
che torna a casa alle 3 di notte ma che
stai facendo
la domanda che sorgeva spontanea spesso
non rispondevo al telefono perché non
prendeva mia madre mi diceva che fine
hai fatto stasera dove sei stata ero
andata una jam che era finita alle 4 di
notte perché non ci eravamo resi conto
neanche di quanto tempo fosse passato a
fare musica
e poi ho iniziato però a rendermi conto
che la musica non era solo e l'america
ma che in realtà soprattutto la mia
città io penso è una città che canta
tantissimo tanto è vero che a napoli se
esci per strada e già senti solo way è
già una musica è già
mantra quasi che possiamo sentire dalle
strade dalle persone da tutti e quindi
mi resi conto che però non avevo
approfondito così tanto la mia
tradizione
ero andata così lontano e non mi ero
reso conto davvero reso conto di cosa
avevo davanti a me lo sapevo davanti
agli occhi e quindi un altro punto di
partenza
spinta dalla passione ho seguito anche
questo ho iniziato ad ascoltare tanta
musica napoletana e ho cercato sempre di
reinterpretarla il mio modo ovviamente e
ho poi pensato in realtà c'è una cosa
che mi diverte spesso sicuramente
dappertutto ci sono persone che vendono
le rose per strada
penso che sia capitato a tutti di
incontrarli una volta nella vita
io faccio sempre una cosa gli dico vita
o 2 euro
però mi dovete insegnare una canzone del
vostro paese ho imparato così tanto da
quelle quattro note di ognuno di loro e
dal modo in cui me l'hanno cantato con
l'amore soprattutto perché ognuno si
sente comunque a casa quando canta è
qualcosa che è così attaccata la nostra
anima è così legata a tutto a tutto
quello che riguarda noi che è una cosa
che non dobbiamo mai assolutamente
dimenticare la mia passione quindi
adesso mi ha portato poi a continuare in
un altro progetto quello della
tradizione appunto accompagnata da tre
amici musicisti napoletani mino lanzieri
alla chitarra antonio napolitano al
contrabbasso e massimo del pezzo alla
batteria e noi quattro insieme abbiamo
cercato di ricercare delle dei brani
appunto delle varie tradizioni e farli a
modo nostro e attraverso questo gruppo
attraverso questo messaggio che vorremmo
mandare siamo stati fortunati perché
lavoreremo tanto anche all'estero
andremo in turchia
a breve quindi faremo tanto proprio con
questa nostra idea di portare la musica
agli altri
un'altra passione per me però è stato
poi cercare di insegnare
gli altri la mia passione insieme a
marina tripodi e il centro della voce
dove sono insegnante ho incominciato
questo nuovo percorso quindi a scoprire
l'insegnamento e vedere la luce negli
occhi dei ragazzi che vogliono imparare
che vogliono studiare e vogliono
coltivare le loro passioni
dal momento che so che ho sempre poco
tempo il timer che ho cercato di volervi
dire tutto in pochissime parole ma la
cosa che vorrei lasciare ai giovani che
ci sono qui in sala è quella di
perseguire sempre i vostri di seguire
sempre i vostri sogni e di non
dimenticare mai qual è la meta che
volete raggiungere perché adesso abbiamo
una miriade di distrazioni di paure
anche spesso dovute a persone che ci
possono prendere in giro se qualsiasi
follia qualcuno vuole seguire ma ci
crede davvero
una passione che bisogna continuare
sempre a seguire e ai genitori come sono
stati alla fine i miei che non ne hanno
mai obbligato a suonare il pianoforte
non mi hanno mai obbligato a fare
classica perché venivamo da venivamo da
quella da quella estrazione
i miei genitori mi hanno lasciato
sognare e si sono resi conto che il mio
sogno era realizzabile in parte
mi sento di averlo realizzato ma non mi
sento mai arrivata quindi altra cosa
importante e continuate sempre a sognare
anche se il sogno si realizza poco alla
volta
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]